ואנחנו בביתו של כבוד הרב שאר ישוב כהן
ברחוב
חורב
ושש בחיפה.
מהתאריך העברי הוא י
י ב.
אדם
תקשיב, אנחנו
בגיל אלף בעדר, לבין פורימי פורת
כבוד הרב,
תספר לי
בבקשה
שלישית, על
הוריך משפחתך מוצא טעם.
נולדתי בירושלים,
הוריי, אבי המנוח, הרב דוד
כהן, שהיה ידוע בשם הרב הנזיר, שהיה
מגדולי תלמידיו
של הרב אברהם יצחק הכהן. קום. זה
צריך, צריך בדרכה שהיה היא
הייתי אומר
המוביל הרוחני של הציונות הדתית.
האנק המחשבה והתורה, שגם הרב הראשי הראשון של ארץ ישראל
עם מי
שאגב הייתה בת דודתו של אבי.
יש מה היה
שר הכוהל?
גם היא וגם אבי התחילו את הציונות שלהם עוד ברוסיה
הצארית. לא הסובייטית.
הם
הם התארסו
לפני שאבי
איזה חולון לברכה נסע
מרוסיה לגרמניה ללמוד השכלה
בא מרקע ישיבתי.
אבי המשפחה היה הרב של הירח ורדים.
אבא למד אצלו ואצל החפץ חיים שגם הוא היה באותה עיירה,
ואחר כך למד בישיבת סלבודקה בישיבת בלואינג
ונסעה עם עוד
קבוצה של בחור ישיבה
עילויים.
לפדרו של אותם הימים שמע ברון דיוויד גינזבורג, הקים
מוסד במיוחד
המצוינים מ תלמידי הישיבות, שילמדו
את חוכמת ישראל, את ההשכלה הכללית.
כדאי רק להזכיר שבין החבורה חברו הכי טוב היה
הנשיא המנוח. זה אומר שזר
היה פרופסור יחזקאל קופמן, שקרתה ותודות האמונה הישראלית
היה
לו תוציא ויס לבסקי שערכת מוזנים, אחר כך
שרירה שכתב מבוא ל כתבי הקודש, ועוד חלק
אישים שכל אחד
אומר אחד אחד היה משהו מיוחד.
הוא נסע לגרמניה, התארס עם בת דודתו שהייתה עימי,
כשאביה היה רב בעיירה קטנה על יד
העץ אמרו בעיירה בשם לוגה
והיה אמור לחזור
בגרמניה. בקיץ היו אמורים להתחתן,
פרצה מלחמת העולם
הראשונה,
פרצה המהפכה
הקומוניסטית. אבל
כל ממני שאני אגיד לכם בעבור שלקית
מתחת קשר ביניהם
למשך
שנה.
חופ אתם עמדה אחרי
שאנו בבתו של הרב קוק בירושלים.
כלומר,
מדוע כל כך הרבה שנים
וזהו בשאלה שהיה עיר
מלחמת העולם הראשונה
זה
חמש. חמש שנים אחר כך
היה השלטון הסובייטי השלטון. הם לא הרשו לה לצאת.
אני גם מבין שכמעט והיא כמעט ונשלחה לסיביר
בגלל מחתרת ציונית
ו
על ידי זה שהרב קוק השיג מתה שלוש
שלטונות המנדט הבריטי. כץ
זה לקח את השנים האלה, פשוט זה לא ככה. זה הלך
בין הארוזים הנישואים.
השנה לפני זה כבר הגיע ארצה, אבל
שנה עברו מהנסיעה שלו. לגבי הלימוד.
באר שבע שנים
בשביל צ היה אחר כך ארבע שנים בגרמניה. של השני מגיע בשביל
הרב קוק.
פגש אותו בשביל צר. היה
מתרשם. האישיות שלו הזמין אותו יותר. אחד המורים של הישיבה שהקים בירושלים
אחרי שהוא
הגיע לירושלים. למעשה, גם בביתו של הרפואה
הייתי אומר
הוזמנו שם
עשה בתוך הישיבה.
אפשר לומר שלא היה קיים.
הם רוצים לי. גם הנישואים
של ההורים שלי, זיכרונה לברכה,
וגם
הלוויה של אבי
היו בבית הרב קוק בירושלים. המוסד נקרא יום בית הרב
שנמצא ברחוב הרב קוק,
שהוא
כך שאפשר לומר שנולדתי בבית הזה.
בשבילי הרב
הצעה
אנחנו קורעים אותו. תלמידה. מרן הרב הזו היה כמו סבא.
כך כך הסתכלתי עליו.
ההורים שלי גרו בשכונת צרפת,
בשכונת נחלת החינוך.
אחד הלך לאות של ירושלים הוותיקה, שבהן
הזיכרון הראשון שלי, וזה אולי מאוד סמלי,
הוא
ילד קטן
בשנת,
בקיץ של שנת אלף תשע מאוד,
או צרפת, לפי מנחם אב, תרפ את פיה
הכנופיות הערביות בתקיפות את החלת אחים.
ואנחנו בורחים
מהשכונה שלנו, שהייתה דאז
בירקיט ירושלים במערב, לפני ש
שולחן החלק האחר, ראש הכנסת היום,
והיה
את פינוי
האזרחים במרכאות.
אז אבי ואימי
לקחו אותי ואת אחותי הגדולה ממני
לדבר איתה. אבל לצפייה קורן אביב בימים
בביתו של הרב קוק
ובירושלים,
שהם בלב העיר וכזה כדי להימלט מההתקפה הזאת
זה העסקה. הזיכרון הראשון שלי זוכר בחיי זה הבעלה הזאת והמעבר מהבית לבית זר.
האישיות של הרב קוק בצה ל וכמה
כבוד קוריוז הוא
או
אפיזודה מאוד חשובה מבחינה היסטורית
באותה שבת הגיעו הידיעות מחברון על הטבע ח
של בחורי הישיבה
והחלק מהאזרחים.
ואני זוכר שכל השבת לא היה שום דבר הממוצע איש הבא. אז אני זוכרת, הפכו קבוצה לא מתה עליך.
בתוך החדר יהיה בחדר קטן
כזה גם
בין סלון, קבלת אורחים גדול
של בית הרב הראשי
הולך ושר לעצמו
בכל כדי להרגיע את הזוג או
להביע את רגשותיו,
הרני נורו. עם
עמוק קידם הוועדה, ועיכוב
ונקם ישיב לצערה וחיברה נתון המוזה. זה
הזיכרון הראשון שיש לי.
הייתי בוודאי.
נולדתי ברביעי לנובמבר.
זה היה ב
באוגוסט
בעוד שנתיים. זה הזיכרון הראשון שלי. יש לי
ממש זכרון הראשון שלי,
וזה מעניין שזה זיכרון ראשון, כי לצערי אינה
הנה אותה ישיבת מרכז הרב. הייתה עכשיו מקום
של לפיגוע, של
טרור, של שמונה בחורים לצעירים
נהרגו
אז אבל הם עושים לי כן,
זה הרקע.
אני חייב לומר
למדתי קודם
במוסד שכרותו תרבות, הוראת פעולה.
המשפחה שלנו עברה
מן החלטה. אחים
ל
בשכונות צפון ירושלים, משפט קרב אברהם
גרנו שם ברחוב עם אוז,
אולי יהיה יותר מדויק, כולל גר ברחוב,
עושה אחר כך בחוץ פאני הרחק בקולמוס
בו תמיד היו הרי עובדים כל
כל מאוחר
מאוחר והיה כל
חודש
אחרי חודש
עבור
אבל ביד בחוק המוסדי שלנו כבר
שם כבר גדלתי.
למדתי את אותות המותר הגאולה שהם בית ספר דתיים
תורני,
כך הייתי אומר
ציוני
למתוח ירושלים. זה לא פשוט
שניהל אותו יהודי בשם
ואני שלום פרידמן,
שהיה כסא של הגברת שפיצר. שיזדיין בית הספר לבנות
תריסר. זה היה אחוז, הייתי אומרת.
את
ציוני דתי שבו גדלתי
עם אוריינטציה לאומית עם רוטציה יותר ציונית, לאומית,
תורנית ולאומית
ביחד,
ו
בגיל מסוים אני חושב שזה
היה בגיל תשע או משהו כזה.
אותי גידלו בייקר,
מעין עילוי.
אבל הסל היה נזיר.
הנזירות שלו מתבטאת בכך שהוא גידל שערות ארוכות,
לא שתה יין.
ממילא היה כהן אז כך שלא להתמלא מתים.
והייתי אומר שהיה
שילוב של פילוסוף
ומקובל
בתלמיד חכם גדול.
אני למליסה
ואותי.
הוא גידל באותה הרוח.
בגיל תשע כבר ידעתי את כל התנ ך בעל פה,
ואני לא מגזים.
אני זוכר או דרך קבע קשה להתמיד לשאנל וכמה שהתרגשתי, וזה לא העיר
ביד קשה.
יחדירו בי תצלח, נתן לו את הכינוי הזה
יו יו ש
או החיים שלו. אז בעצם תלמידה וחבריו
כמה כאותה הנזיר
הנו הנוזל
לוזר.
אתה גדלת. עבר דירה כאן עם האמירה הזאת
אתה.
אשתי אומרת שגידלו אותי לראות, להיות משיח,
כאילו היא
קדושה וטהרה כזאת.
אבל זה היה בית מאוד מיוחד. הייתי אומר שכל גדולי התורה של ירושלים, של אותם הימים,
כל גדולי הציונות עם בני בית.
הזכרתי קודם את הנשיא זלמן שזר. אני זוכר שאבא כל שנה
בחו ל
בי ללא שנה רבה
הסוכה של
חברו בינואר, אבל אז ללמוד שם
יחד
קבלה.
כך הם מעבירים את התיקון ללא שנה רבה.
אז הדירה שגדלתי בה
רבה. בגיל
שנים ויום אחד
התכנסו רבני ירושלים, איזה עשרים רבנים חשובים מאוד,
כמו
שעשה ובאמצעותו צה ל.
עוד
דוד איש היה
אחרי
חותנו
רבה שלא תירה. הרדיד,
ועוד רבים מאוד. אחרי סדר הלב. עיכוב שתיים
היה וגם כן
גדולי התורה בירושלים
הביא עוד רבנים איתו,
ואני מסרתי הודעה שאני אמנם ממשיך
להתנהל בדרך של נזירות, אבל אני לא מתחייב. זה לא נעדר.
אני רק כל מה שאני רוצה אני יכול.
אומנם באמת
בגיל
הפסקתי את הגידול, הזרועות הארוכות,
זה היה כבר
הייתי כבר פעיל בתנועת נוער, תן לדבר עליה,
וזה כבר הפריע לי. כן, זה שנים. אני הייתי גם
בגיל קצת יותר מבוגר
במחתרת,
קודם בעצם לחקר וההגנה,
וזה הפריע.
ואז קונספירציה לכל העניין.
אז בגיל שש עשרה היה עוד טקס לא רגיל בירושלים, של
גזיזת סערות על ידי
מספרים מיוחדות של כסף,
גם קימוט האם גדולים בסעודה וכן הלאה.
אבל
אני נשארתי מבחינת אוכל,
כמו שהוריי נהגו. גם
אבי וגם אימי היו צמחונים
בבס בשר לא נכנס לבית שלנו.
בנו את בשר על הגב. לא עוף ולא דגים. לשבת פה שום דבר חי
ולא יין
משקאות
בעצם עיקר עיקריה עידוד.
אה,
אז הכיס, הקידוש של הרב הנזיר היה על חיילות ועל מיץ
בארבר לעשות
אותו דבר הביס תפוחים.
תפוחים.
כן,
זה הרקע. כלומר, הכבוד מיוחד במינו.
הייתי אומר שגידלו אותי להיות זה מין בילוי כזה
היא מתמרדת התמדתם בכיוון זה שלחתי לישיבה אחרת. זה ישיבת פתח תקווה.
עכשיו פונים יש לו את הילד
וסינון האחר של הישיבות.
העלון הזה
התחלנו אותה לעבר,
אבל אתה גדלתי
ואם
בגיל
די צעיר הצטרף לתנועת נוער
שהיא לא קיימת היום,
אבל כתבו עליהם, אפילו שדרו עליה ברעיון של מסגרת. את
רגע אחד, שישי בשנה
בחנוכה, הברית החשבונאיים,
הפרידה, שהיתה תנועת נוער, שהיית מאמין ביתר דתית,
ש
רוב חבריה היו
קולמן שהיה אצל אנשי הנכים.
הראש של התנועה היה מפקד האצ ' לפני
מנחם בגין,
כשהוא היה משה סגל,
השיבו הידוע
והזקן הארוך,
סופיה היה איש חוות גריף. כבר חבל,
היה ברור דובדבני שם כמה דרוש. אבל התעקשת, הסוכנות ואחרים.
אני הייתי
מהמדריכים של הטובה הזאת ולומר לך, מהאנשים את הערכתי את העיתון של
עיתון בשבע חשמונאי.
וזה היה הייתי אומר, מבחינה רוחנית או ליד
המטרה.
נו אז מולידה של
כל הכיוון
הציונית
תורני לאומי, שהם כל המתיישבים ביהודה ושומרון
גדלו על אל מרכז. אפשר לומר שזה מילה מסוימת, הוא
הרקע הרוחני.
הבית בגוש אמונים,
אגב סיעוד היקוק,
הרי הבת בראש הקבוצה הזאת.
וזה
נולד באותו
אותה השאירה אותו מרכז הרב שלי. למעשה, למדתי בעשר שנים
היו חברך על
קבוצה לגיל שלכם בקבוצת הגיל שלך,
אמרת אל הרב סגל.
אני אף פעם הייתי בביתי עם קבוצת הגיל שלי. זה אולי מוזר לומר הזאת היא העובדה
שעל פי ראיתי עם אנשים מבוגרים ממני.
אבל היו אנשים
כמו משה נ ה זכרונו לברכה. יש ספר עליו יחשיבו במה זכרונו לברכה חדשה.
עכשיו נפטר בירושלים.
יש לי
קובץ תמונות זה
ישר ספר שעומד כאן
ברית החשמונאים.
אתה יכול לראות אותו שם המונח
ב
בתוך הארון בצד,
אתה רואה אותו,
אתה לא רואה אותי,
אני אומר נקרע אותו לקראת כן,
יש לי טופס אחרת. אבל
זה
דוקטורט שכתב בחור בשם הגישה יש היה חניך שלי. כבר
יש עוד בחור בשם לעבוד לוויתה של שניכם לכם את השחרור שגר בעיר עתיקה שהיה חניך שלי.
יש היום מעטים נשארו אותה.
סליחה
בשנים
היה טקס של יקירי
ירושלים.
היו שם מסר אותי מסר,
יקירים ארבעה יוצא בית החשבונאי
אותו שמעון במה שהזכרתי היה
השגת את זכריה,
כולל האנשים שפעם ירושלים, רובם ירושה, הייתה התנועה הייתה או בירושלים או בתל אביב.
בזה אלה משני המקומות שהיא הייתה.
ויק אל בית הפלא
התפרקה עם כל המדינה מתוך מחשבה של חבריה שעשינו תפקידנו. קמה מדינת ישראל.
אבל אני
אותו מאותו ספר שיצא לכם.
הדוקטורט של השלושה הוא לבי שיש כאן אלברט השכונה עם שחסה בבר אילן
וכתוב שם התנגדו כזו. שהתנגדתי, אמרתי עתרה, אתם טועים.
החינוך הזה צריך להמשיך אותו, כי באים כאן אנשים. זה
ניתן שהם באים אליו
מרקע אידיאולוגי
ולא היישוב היהודי הקטן, הציוני האידיאולוגי שהיה,
אבל לא שמעו בקולי.
הרוב יחידה אחרת שהיה חיים קוברסקי זכרונו לברכה, שהיה מנכ ל משרד הפנים,
יקודם יחד איתי עם עיריית ירושלים. היה מנהל מחלקת החינוך של ירושלים.
הוא היה בין אלה שלחמו בשביל
לפרק. גמרנו. לא צריך יותר.
למעשה
אין היום בתוך התנועה
הזאת, שלמעשה גם בעיטה כבר לא קיימת היום,
אבל לא יודע בשבועיים. וודאי שלא קיימת
בני עקיבא. לך עם מידה מסויימת את הדרך הזאת.
אז היה להגיש ההתיישבות, היו יותר לחימה בצה ל וכן הלאה.
אתה
לומד
לימודים
בישיבה, כפי שציינת את כן. אבל אני בכל הזמן למדתי גם לימודים
וקרניים על ידי
ברורים מיוחדים שבאו אליי הביתה.
גם את סיום בית הספר
היסודי.
אז אותו פרידמן זה
הוציא אותי בבית הספר בגיל
שמונה. משהו כזה,
להרגיש אותי רק לתורה
הילד, הנזירים, השערות הארוכות.
אבל
בגיל
ומשהו
אי אפשר להיבחן
בבית הספר. כלומר
כאחד מהתלמידים, וקיבלתי תעודת גבר
חייך. למדתי
בחינות בגרות.
יש בשיעורים להודות מטרי כל היישוב,
ואז גם היא מורה פרטי.
למדתי אנגלית זה
את את
וההורים לא חסכו
למורים פרטיים מחודש שטחים
אני, אני מורה לתנ ך ללשון עברית
שהיה ידוע שמואל יעקב בן שלמה. זאת ניגשה אל קבר
את המבוא לספר יו
האם הם
הורים מעולים.
אבל אמרתי תוך יחס מיוחד
אני כבר
עסקה שהערכתי את העיתון. כתבתי כבר
החיבור הראשון שלי
במרכאות, חיבור
מאמר על הרב קוק אחרי פטירתו, את
אופייה ביסוד
העיתון שבוע מחריבי שהופיע בתל אביב,
בריחתו של ישראל חוואס
שאני הייתי אז רק
בן
תשע, עשר.
משהו כזה.
אני זוכר שהכותרת הגירעון הדור,
וכתוב שם מתנשף פרייה, כותב המאמר, הוא בנו של תלמידו של
זה. הדבר הראשון,
הנאום הראשון שלי בחיי היה בבית
כנסת אישור בירושלים, בגיל
באזכרה של הרב קוק.
אגב, אני גם צריך דרשת בר המצווה קבורה
כמובן. בסדר. המשרה התחברה
בעצם על ידי בשיתוף בדרכה של אבא שלי.
אני גם כתבתי ספר בשם אסיפה טאליהו שמעולם לא נתפס
אל
הגמרות שלמדתי.
זה החמיא לי מאד
אם יתפסו ספרים שני אחרים יותר מאוחר כבר שהגעתי
עכשיו, אחרי שהגעתי כבר לגיל
ארבעים
בזה.
אבל הרקע הזה, התורני הלאומי, זה הייתי אומר, מאפיינת את
הקשר לזה. אל תגיד מתגייס לעצם
אמרת
העשר היה כבר בגיל
בגיל חמש.
כן,
אבל
קודם היית בעצם אחרי זה בא,
כי
מה שקרה זה שיש כמה תנועת המרי
העברי שזה היה הניסיון של לובוצקי. אני חושב, אחד ממנהיגי הצוהר,
ליצור מחתרת מאוחדת.
הניסיון שלו היה מבין את הפיגוע במלון קדמית
ושאז
להתפרק.
אז
ברית החשמונאים שמינה באחדות
זאת לוחמת
עבור רוב.
רוב חניכיה
עברו
להגנה לגדול במיוחד. הקבוצה מיוחדת.
טוב, מוריה שהייתה שייכת לנו
באותה קבוצה
נשארה בהגנה. חלק
ימשיך ברכב באותו הזמן.
פחות באיזה יותר בלחי
עריקאת הלחש יותר אינדיבידואליות, פחות
דגש הצבאיות יותר.
ברוך
בואך. רוב החברים היו
ברובם אנשי ההגנה, חלקם השלכת.
והסיבה שהגענו לעיר העתיקה של ירושלים. מלחמת השחרור.
דבר מזה שסאם היה המקום היחידי שלא היו
שלוש המחתרות.
אתה יודע, מפקדה מיוחדת,
שבראשה כולם אדישה הגנה והלפרין אחר תשלחי משהו סנקציות. שניהם זכרונם לברכה.
אש
לשם.
מי שרצה לא ללכת.
אחד הגופים לכולם ביחד
הלך לשם.
ישיבת מרכז הרב הייתה חממה של
שלושת המחתרות.
תמיד רזיאל
מפקד האס אס, למד בישיבת מרכז הרב
להיות זוכר אותו בילדותי
בשל איך? בוודאי שהיו
רבים פונה שהזכרתי קודם,
כמו שמובא מסרו לאהרון לוויתן ואחרים
וראשי ההגנה
זו הייתה היא. כבר
אין.
אחותך הייתה נשואה לרב גורן.
אז עוד לא.
לא זה זה קרה. ביי אחר כך.
כן, זאת אומרת, זאת אומרת, זה להיות יותר מדויק.
כשהייתי בשבי זה כבר הרב גורן פרייד עשוי
קודם.
מה קודם?
כן,
למיטב ידיעתי
שברחו אנשי מלחים
במנהרה מבית הסוהר, התחלת שכבר מתכבד סויים בבית בצו, הביט אחורה עזה בירושלים.
וזה שמוליק.
תשמע, תשמע, לויס. והוא גם מזכיר את זה בזיכרונות שלו.
אני חושב שאני עשוי לדעת.
כבר היה נשוי. אגב, צריכה להיות עכשיו
חתונה
של
נכד של ארגון הוודו, של בנו
יחידו, עברה בשבוע ואמרו עוד עשרה ימים
והתאריך המדויק. קשה לי לומר לך כרגע, אבל
אני למדתי בישיבת מרכז הרב
לפני מלחמת השחרור.
אביב שליו, גורר. עבדתי בחברות. האם אתה גורם בעצמו
שגיסי
מרוגה בדירה ברחוב עזה,
שהיום זאת מיכה וחבריו, הבר סוג זה חלק מאיזושהי נמשך הלאה.
זה היה כבר שלוש ארבע שנים.
הוא הרי עוד מלחמת העולם
השנייה.
התפרסם שהוא נתן שיעור על בעיית השבת
ושלחה אי
יום הכיפורים בשם. בחיי
היה
קו התאריך.
הכנס
הגיע שאלה מפליטי הישיבה ישיבת מיר שהגיעו נשלחה אל הרב הרצוג
איך לעשות את מתה לעשות את הצום
עם באותו זמן שעושים זאת אומרת ישראל, או ביום אחר.
מה עשו כינוס במלון בירושלים,
רחוב בן יהודה שלא נפגע בפיצוץ המפורסם בניגוד אבל לא למדו סי
ואחד האילו. אם הצעירים שדיבר
היה שלמה בארון שהיא, שאז היה
במגורון שלו גורם
הוא כבר אז
הוא היה מאורס
לאחותי.
הנישואים שלהם אתכם בירושלים באותו מלון
תחום
אתה כחבר הגנה או חבר עצם, ולאחר מכן חבר הנהלת העברת האימונים במשק
פה
לפני שנפגע הגנת בהגנה. כן,
בעצם פחות. הם
ניסו אותי יותר
לצרכים ספרותי. אם הייתי אומר
לא
לימדו. אולי
שימוש
בדו ח ו
ושטיין אני חושב.
אבל כוס ממש כוס ואין קורס ומקיפים שהיה גם כוס של מקרנים וכן הלאה.
הראשון שהשתתפתי פה זה היה בבית של אותו בית המריבה
בגוש עציון.
זה בין
עין צורים
ומסורות יצחק,
שם היו מקרים באחוזים של ההגנה.
וזה היה המגע הראשון שלי עם גוש עציון.
בוודאי.
זה היה
שנתיים
לפני שהבריטים עזבו.
הרבה
פעמים
פשוט הזה
טוב, שום דבר.
כן,
זה היה. זה כבר היה בתוך הייתי
איש גדוד מוריה
שלך, איש.
איך קראו ליחידה עליו?
הקבוצה המיוחדת שלכם בתוך גדוד מוריה שהיה של אני לא נכנסתי.
אני חושב
שהיה
אם היה שם מיוחד, לא יודע. הייתה פלוגה מיוחדת. הוא גם
ידעו שזה
אם אתה גם בחשבונות לאנשי השמאל 'יש תתייחסו אלינו. זה מנהל
כך הם לא שאנחנו
מעין
שייכים לשנייה. שתי המחתרות. הכרת בטהיטי כמובן את הרב
אריה לווין,
בוודאי הבין איזה הימית
יש אפילו תמונות כאלה
יש פה. זה אתה רואה את
הקרטון הזה
עם
האירים
מוכן אפילו שתיקח אותו.
זו תמונה של הרב קוק ותלמידיו
של המרכז. הרב קוק בצד ימין
הפכה ל ואבא שלי בצד שמאל, אגף ציודה וארבעה ילדים.
הרב אריה לווין
היה
תלמיד מובהק של הרב קוק
ואני גדלתי
אצלו עד לכך
שבימים נוראים
היו תלמידי ישיבת מהחזרה מתפללים בבניין
הישן של דמות הורה עץ חיים בשכונת מחנה יהודה.
הבעל שחרית היה
חד משמעי בעל מוסך היה אריה לווין
וב זיכרונות שלא
מובן
שכתבו עליו
שהיה אומר לי
לשתוק. קחי את הילדים שלך, אבל אז הראויות אמרה יעשו בתפילה ולשים לב. הם צריכים לאכול
ביום כיפור
אפילו קטנטנים. עדיין
כך שברי לווין בשבילי היה בן בית היה ואת בר ביצוע. שלי היה
בכל הטקסים שהזכרתי. קודם של הנזירות.
הוא היה פה. יש לי ברחוב את טופס שניקח יד אל יד
כדרכו
ואומר שונה, אבל הרכב המברך באהבה. כך היה
הבעיה. היא מבינה, אני גם
אולי צריך להזכיר זה לא יודעים כל כך.
אני נעצרתי על ידי הבריטים,
שמצאו את שמי באחת הרשימות של של מישהו מהעצם שהיה גר
באי מול הבית שאנחנו גם
חובה. מוס בירושלים,
בחור בשם יוסף בית הזונות שהיו לה
לקניין,
והוא
כנראה הייתה לו רשימה של
אלה שהוא היה קשור איתם במחתרת. הייתי בתוך
אז הופיע. אני עוד זוכר עד היום את
המכונית השחורה של
אי עשייה, הביאה
פולשת הברית ומופיע ליד הבית שלנו. ואני רואה ובורח למעלה
לדובר זו סרה בקפיצה ונעלמתי להם
עד שהם מצאו אותי.
בואו לישיבת מרכז הרב ודיברו עם ראשי הישיבה
להם טיפים בית, כמה פני
וכן הלאה. בקיצור, אני נעצרתי
פעם אחת ליד הכותל המערבי בן תשעה באב,
כשאנשי בן השמונה הצטרפו לקבוצה.
לא התוקע היה, וכמו שעסק אבל לא היית, כי היה שירת התקווה, ליל תשעה באב ליד הכותל.
אז אסור אותי. לקחו אותי להקיש
ושחררו אותי אחר כך,
אבל הייתי כבר חשוב ביניהם.
לקחו אותי לנטרון.
ישבתי סך הכל שבועיים בלטרון.
כנראה העיר
ירושלים
הרבנית והדתית הפכה עולמות,
אמר לי היה קצין
המשטרה. בגלל זה פרישה קובע לי שגם ראשי ההגנה וגם ראשי האם
הארגון, המשרד
הסוהר משתדלים של אותו אדם,
בדרך כלל לוחמים ביניהם,
אבל זה היה בזכותו של אבא. כמובן הבסיסי הוא די
די נדיר, שגם היית אסיר
אצל הברית איתי, והוא היה גם את זה לא ירדן.
כן, זה זכיתי להיות בחור ישיבה,
בחור ישיבת
שנתיים, משמע כן, אז זה היה
אני זוכר את החקירות שהיו לי.
צריך לומר שהיא
כבר להיות הציר והסיר הזה אצל הבריטים,
עם כל ההתנהגות הרעה שלהם, היתה היתה להם את של כל מניעות מסוימת,
ואני זוכר את הסמל
שהיה מאחורי החוקר שחקר אותי בשיא ידידים ירושלים
לידי. זה היה
ממנו. אם
תגיש טיפה
הוא הקטנה. יש לנו
לקוח מאחד המשוררים
תוזיז
בסיס ביאליק בבליינד
פריסבי צ'וז
ביוור העיקרית.
זה סמל מאחורי החוקר.
קצת צביעות.
קאוון הייתה עשר, אבל עצם הרעיון שצריך לירות באדם שנחקר מן פנים שוחקות כאלה,
זה אומר משהו.
אני לא בטוח שהיה קורה אצל כיסתה פה אצל ההיקף ידי דבר כזה,
אבל למעשה זה
המאסר. היה יותר נכון מהשחרור,
כי החלו להוציא ממני אינפורמציה רבה, אבל ברוך השם זה עבר בסדר.
אני זוכר שמי שדיבר
בשבילי אם מצד אחד לא כבר על תיבת
הי אבא זיכרונו לברכה. מצד שני יהודה גולן, זיכרון הרווחה שהיה
מזכיר או שלמו ששרת
קודם. יש לי שני הצדדים האלה.
אני חושב שאולי גם הרב גורמי היה לו יד בהשתדלות הזאת,
לייסי וקה, חתנו של הרב הנזיר,
מגיעה תקופה של לפני מלחמת השחרור.
אחד הזיכרונות החיים
זה ליל
שריצ'י בנובמבר
יותר
צמודים למכשירי הרדיו
שמשדרים ילקס אקסס
את ההצבעה ההיסטורית.
בסוף את נופלת ההחלטה להקים מדינה
יוני בארץ ישראל.
תום הייתה אחת חלוקה היום.
הרבה לא מבינים איך כך התלהבנו מזה. חצי ארץ ישראל לא שלנו. אבל מי שיודע מה
בחשבו יקודם ואיך לחמו משלכם
ועלו לגרדום. ולכן, במשך שנים
להיפטר מהבריטים שבגדו במדף שקיבלו
מהמהומות
מחבר הלאומים.
אז היה שמחה בירושלים
משהו משהו,
ואנחנו
החברה שלי, עם היחידה המיוחדת של ההגנה
מופיעים אותו, לוקחים אותי לעשות שמח ברחובות.
איך רקדנו ולי את הסוכנות.
גולדה מאיר הופיעה ונעלמה לפנינו
מנכ ל מרכז כיכר ציון.
חלק היו עם נשק
שכבר
קיבלו התראה להיות מוכנים לכל התפתחות שיכולה להיות,
וידיות סוחר
ש בבית הרב קוק בירושלים,
הלך
אליו
מביתו בשערי חסד. הרב יעקב משה חרל עבדה אצל ראש הישיבה.
בחדר הקטן לחדרו של הרב קוק
ישבו שניהם,
ואנחנו תלמידים, הלך לראות מה קורה ושמענו שהם בוכים
במקום לשמוח.
מה אם בחור
אגב ציוד, אבל החלב אל חברון שלנו, על השכנים שלנו,
על באר שבע שלנו
זה מה שאכפת להם,
ולנו היה קשה לתפוס.
ובתוך השמחה הזאת, דווקא כאן, בבית הזה בוכים.
אבל כך זה היה,
ובכל זאת, זה
זה משהו מיוחד. הלילה הזה
ואז בתוך ישיבת מרכז הרב בתחילת תפיסה
מה
יותר נכון
לשבת ללמוד תורה,
לקיים מה שנאמר בדיוידי חזר
עומדות היו רגלינו משאלה ירושלים.
מי גרם להם לרגלינו שייתן היום במלחמה שערי ירושלים שהיו עוסקים בתורה?
אתם בני הישיבה, זה השירות הלאומי שלכם.
אחרי לילה חמודה, תשוקה יומם ולילה אתם לתורה בזכותכם.
פגישה אחת
שבעצם שרתה בישיבות הגדולות,
לא הציוניות, זה
כמעט לא היו. יש בה ציוניות. היה
התחלה של ישיבת כפר הרואה בשנה. הרב משה צבי נריה
נכון, אני לא יודע,
מרכז הרב כמובן, אבל כל היתר ישיבות ליטאיות
או חסידיות
והם כולם הלכו לבן גוריון ואחר כך והשיגו את את
ההסדר שעד היום בתוקף
החזון איש מעגלה התאונה. הרעיון
לא רק חייב לשמור עליו,
מה שירשים את בן גוריון. זה היה בכי של ראשי הישיבה
אחרי מה שקרה ואיש זר. מינצר החברה ואחרי מה שקרה באירופה עם חורבן ושרף את כל הישיבות
שתישאר כאן איזשהי
ועל ידי הליכה לצבא
עלולות הישיבות להתבטל.
אנחנו היינו בידיעה שאנחנו לא פתורים,
וש
מלחמה על ארץ ישראל היא לא פחות חשובה מללמוד תורה.
הרי כאן אומר גדולה ישיבת ארץ ישראל שיש כולם כל המצוות שבתורה.
אנחנו תלמידיו של הרב הנזיר שלבים הורים של הרב צבי יהודה.
חשבנו אחרת
והסיפור כבר התפרסם, אבל לא
כדאי כי לחזור עליו
כן
קאם בירושלים,
משרד שאותו מרכז המפקד לשירות העם.
זה היה לשכת הגיוס בדרך לפני המדינה.
זה קם בראשית שנת
ינואר. משהו כזה.
מי ניהל אותו?
אחד מראשי הישיבה של מרכז הרב,
חתנו של הרב נתן רענן קורס, שהיה חתנו של הרב קוק הגדול,
שהוא היה רע מאוד, החייל לרפורמה
זכרונו לברכה. והוא ניהל,
ארגן את ההתייצבות,
לא רק של
בני הישיבות, מחר של ירושלים
דרכים, ולכן תרחיש קיזחהל משמר
כדי לשמוע מהרב גם כן למשטרה. מסר
כלשהו בוא ניראה את זה.
ואז ביוזמתי,
התחלנו לארגן
קבוצה
שהגרעין ההיא
תלמידים מרכז הרב. אני צפוי גם בישיבת חברון, משימות אחרות
שרוצה לפתור שתי בעיות
אחת
לא לווייתן, לימוד תורה וכן להילחם בשביל ירושלים ולהגן עליה.
והדבר השני, לא
להיכנס למחלוקת שבעיני אצל הלחי וההגנה
במקום היחידים. ירושלים, כמו שהזכרתי קודם,
היה העיר העתיקה של ירושלים,
עם קול ירושלים. למצור
עם השיירות היא בדיקה והכניסה של העיר של
כל מוכן. את נכנסת עדי החל המשמר.
העיר העתיקה הייתה מצאו בתוך מסור.
כן,
הרוב היהודי מסביב הערבים
שרשרת עמדות של הכנופיות הערביות ואחר כך
לעבור לעיר החדשה דרך אזור ביטחון בריטי
שאת
רב מחוברת
לראות עין
בשבילי. בית הסוכנות היהודית אמר זאת אדומים ויוצאים בשערות
פעם בשבוע לשם,
ואנחנו חשבנו שזה המקום המתאים בשבילך.
הרעיון היה לייסד ישיבת
לחימה והגנה
שהסדר יש שם,
אני חושב כולנו, ביחד עם בתי הכנסת של העיר עתיקה
והגדולים
נהיה
חלק ממערך ההגנה של
של
כוח המגן של הרוב היהודי
שבתוכו היו איזה
לוחמים,
בחורי ישיבה שילמדו שמונה שעות ביום
שיעמדו בעמדה, שמונה שעות ביום,
היתר השעות לצרכים האישיים,
אוכל ושינה וכולי.
אתה יודע, אפשר לומר שמבחינה היסטורית
זה ההתחלה
של
מה שעכשיו ידוע ישיבות ההסדר שיש בהם אלפים
ושבה התקרב. הלוחמות של צה ל יהיו למדרגות
המובילות ולראות מישהו אמר שהיא ללשכת הרמטכ ל, שנהיית זאב. אתה רואה כיפות סרוגות
שיושבות עם
דרגות גבוהות.
זו הייתה ההתחלה. עוד לפני הרבנות הצבאית.
זה
הרב שלמה גורן זכרונו לברכה, שיד אישה
אמרתי. השיא
היה גם כן איש הגנה,
אבל הוא נשאר בעיר החדשה ועמד בעמדה הדרך בתה יש תמונות, שלוש עומד עם
או וכן הלאה.
ואני קיבלתי את הגיבוי. גם מארב צפויה הוא וגם אבי מורי, הרב הנזיר,
בניגוד לעמדת תו של
יתר ראשי הישיבות,
שזה לגיטימי,
זה לא פוגע
בה בלימוד התורה, וזה
מוציא אותנו.
אמרת קבוצתכם? כשנכנסתם לעיר עתיקה
הצלחנו להגיע רק איזה ארבעה חמישה.
הקבוצה היתה
אישה,
משהו כזה.
חלק מהם נהרגו אחר כך.
יש לי כאן ספר שנקרא מגילת מלחמה ושלום. אולי זה כן מעניין
כשתראו אותו.
הוא יצא
הרבה אחר כך,
אבל פה מופיע
זה מי כתבי הרב הנזיר
פה מופיע
הפסק
ויצא בירושלים את הפשעים למידע, לעזרה, ביחד. יותר מאוחר,
אז שהגיש מלחמה שהם שמו.
הוא
מופיע
לבני הישיבות בצבא ישראל בשנת בשנחאי.
זה
על רקע אותו הוויכוח.
לא הכל ישנו כאן,
אבל
יש פה מאמר של הרב הנזיר שנקרא
מלחמת מצווה. מלחמת רשות למלחמת חובה, הלוחות מלחמה,
אחר כך
פרטי רוחות מלחמה
ואחת יש כאן.
כן,
גם רשימת החברה שלי,
תלמידי מרכז הרב שנהרגו במלחמת השחרור, וגם
בקרבות שאחר כך
עד ועל מחלקם הציפורים.
וגם הפה פסק הלכה שצריך על חסר. כי
מישהו,
אבל
קצת באירוע פסק
כאילו היא יודעת
ש
שאומר למעשה
שאלה שאומרים שלא צריך ללכת.
נאמר עליהם בשירת דבורה
מפלגות ובין גדולים וחייגי לב
למה ישנו בין המשפטי
ופה מופיע הרעיון,
יש לקבוע סדרים ומועצת.
לדעתך אחרי הישיבות, הרבנים הראשיים שלו איבדו מוסדות התורה והישיבות, כי
זה טום חם
בשידור. פלוגות בסדר, הוגים.
זה מה שקרה אחר כך.
זה היה
הפסקה על מכתב שאני הייתי בשב
אבל.
אבל זה ידוע
כי דנתי את החוברת הזאת. אם אתם עושים זה תיעוד.
אתה רואה, כאן ישנו
היותר החלולים
פטי החללים.
מה רצית לספר?
בבקשה,
כבר מספר בבקשה. כיצד נכנסתם לדירה? זהו סיפור
הא?
הדרך הייתה סגורה
אחת לשבוע היתה יורדת שירה
וועדת תולעת ואתה מסתכל על זה
כשאתה יוצאת מ
חצר הסוכנות היהודית בירושלים,
היא מביאה אספקה,
מביאה
בחשאי
גם נשף
והאנשים שהם או מורים או רופאים,
אחיות,
מזל אנשים שחזקים לי להביא אותם.
ההסכם הבריטים שהם היו לוקחים אותנו בשיירה שלהם.
אני זוכר שבמשך כמה שבועות הייתי באה בכל יום שני ורביעי עם וזה היה
אז היה שיירות דיילי
לזכות להסתנן.
בסופו של דבר
נכנסתי
לשיירה הבריטית שעברה דרך אזור הביטחון שלהם.
במגררת קראו את זה אז
בירושלים
והשכיבו אותי על קולי
מזוודות ו
והיה שם זה שגם
סוגי הנשק האישי
בטלית ותפילין כמובן,
וכיסו אותה מבריזה.
כשהגענו לשאר יפו נשואה
אנשי הכנופיות לעשות
עם
כידונים, והבריטים לא נתנו להם,
כי זה כי זה וכשהגענו ללהק עיקר
אותה בשם הספרדי. חכו רע בין שער ציון לרוב היהודי ושם מגרש חניה,
אז שווה. עשו לנו קבלת פנים כאילו כאילו מה שהיא ארבעה.
אני הייתי יחידה זה בוטל. שירה ש מהקבוצה של תלמידי הישיבות.
את הבאה מאלתרים, שהיה מפקד הגנב, העיר עתיקה. הוציאו אותי בכוח מתוך הרב מתוך
הזבל.
אז הפקד המשה רוסיה, שרק מרגיש בית החשמונאים,
והיה איש לחיבה משני הכי בעצמו.
כן,
משהושג זיק, ממש נכפה עליו. הר כגיגית. כן, טוב, כי לא הייתה ברירה
והסגן שלו קרעו אותו, אישר נתנזון
והוא היה אישה. את את זה.
וזה מן שילוב כזה. הגנה. אצל לחיה חשב לא הייתה בעיה לכולם.
עסקו בהגנת העיר עתיקה בקרבות,
ואני נפצעתי בה
ביום הרביעי של הקרבות.
קשה
ברגל.
לקחו אותי לבית חולים, הראי שלנו יושבים עם משגב לדך. כזה היה שם.
לא עשו הרבה, פשוט
קברו את הרגל בתוך הגבס.
הגז היה
אני אמרתי מתוך עמדה,
והיא פגז,
פגע מהעמדה
הגז הערבי
אתה בעמדה?
אלוהים, זה היה כבר שאני יודע ירדן הגיע להצטרף עם הנשף
או
יום לפני זה
זה לקח עוד שבועיים בערך עד שהיא
עיר עתיקה. תתפסו את החזק, המדינה שלהם ירד.
שמעתי טו בעיצומם של הקרבות. עוד
הייתי מאוד
ממונה על יחידת מרגמות.
אחד הכרוזים שעבדתי בגוש עציון היה
שימוש ומרגמות,
חיות פרימיטיביות. כמובן,
הטילים של היום ודאי הרבה יותר מפותחים מזה, אבל זה
הסדר היה מאוד מעניין.
העילה יקירתי, גם מתלה וגם מר אמא.
הייתי גם ביחידה כזאת. גם יחידת
החליפו אותנו.
היו איזה עשרים עמדות.
אתם צריכים לרוץ מעמדה לעמדה, ואני רוצה שיחשבו שיש לנו בכל עמדה
את הנשק הזה.
זה
נכתב ספר לבור, טיט לילדים
בעיר העתיקה, ילדים את
תושבי העיר עתיקה שהיו
מעשה הכשרים שלנו.
החלל הצעיר ביותר
במלחמת העצמאות היה קשה אצלכם על צבא בעיר העתיקה.
אני ממש אמרתי נבצענו קשה וכבר אני זוכר שעץ
המשך הקו אותך בתוך
אתה כבר היית
פצוע ושאולי תזונה. אחת ששכחתי לספר זה עם הרב צבי יהודה הכהן קוק,
אלה שהתנגדו לי
שביקשת מדי שלא ילכו לצבא,
מצאו בכתבי הרב קוק
איגרת שלו
ששמה הוא כותב בידו אני לא צריך לגייס בישיבות
ש
שאמרת
ממנה לא צריכים שתראו אותה והם צריכים ללמוד תורה ולא מגיעה לגזענים.
לא נהנה ש
אז
יש עשה
הנגרמת בני חכמים מקיימת
מין
קצת הלכה ממש
קיצוני נגד
הדפיסו את זה על קוז והדביק אוזל
בחוצות ירושלים כולל הכניסה לישיבת מרכז הרב.
אני עובד באחד הימים הישיבה רואה את זה
על דלת הכניסה זה ועידה? מתי
מה אני הולך לעשות משהו נגד הרב קוק? מה קרה? אה,
עכשיו
אני מדבר על
האחוז הזה
אני
אתם מכירים חבריו הוא
גיבה. יורדים בכיכר ציון
אני יורד לכיכר ציון, כולי לבן
והנה הוא הולך לקראתי הרב סבירה פוינטקורפ
הולך לישיבה,
נעצר על ידי ראה אותי
אמרתי לו כבר שלום
והוא הכיר אותי טוב,
אז הוא רואה שהפנים שלי לבנות מה קרה אז הוא התחיל לשאול אותי מה איש רע קרה שישוב?
מה קרה?
יש
משהו? כן,
אני זה הפסקה ויש לך את החומר
כאילו תהיה כזה. כותב ב'מקור ראשון' מהסופר.
אה,
סיפרת לו
להפסיד? יודע,
אני שומע את
צלצול
הטלפון. אתה יודע, בבקשה. יכול להיות שאתה צריך לקבל שיחות נוספות.
יכול להיות עלייה
טוב.
אז סיפרתי לו,
תקשיב, יש כוס כזה,
ואני אחרי נמצא במצב לא נעים מצד הרגשתי קבוצה בישיבה הייר
לכאורה עם ההסכמה של שלום ושל אבי,
טכנו לדרכה
היתה שלי. אם הם ועם הרב קוק נגדך זה
אני לא יודע מה לעשות.
יש ככה שהוא יתאמץ ככה
בכעס
וצעק בקול גדול זיוף, זיוף.
אני בקושי הרגשתי אותו.
ואז הוא הסביר לי שהמכתב הזה נכתב על ידי הרב קוק לארץ בבריטניה,
מלחמת העולם הראשונה שעליו של מחזיקי הדת
נגד גיוס לצבא הבריטי.
איך אפשר להשוות מלחמה
אם הצבא הבריטי נגד גרמניה של עז של וילהלם
לא יודעים מי הנאצי
אם אינך בשביל ירושלים של ארץ ישראל,
אני אומר כבוד הרב, שהרב לכתוב לזה
אני צריכים לפרסם את זה.
אני מוכן לכתוב על עם דפוס שידפיס, כאילו היה דפוס בירושלים. כולם היו
מושבתים. לא היה דלק.
מתניה סיידר. שידפיסו את זה.
אני עוד זוכר שאני הלכתי
למשרד לפני זכרונו לברכה, שהיה אז יושב ראש ועדת
ואד המצב או משהו כזה. אבל הקהילה
וסידרתי שדפוס רונאן כשהיה בחצר עלייה זו ירושלים ידפיס את
החוברת שיוציא את הסיוע
שנקראת אל משמר העם הישראלי.
התפיסה של מאז כמה פעמים יש לי עוד את
אותה את המהדורה הראשונה עם הקדשה שלו.
עכשיו הוא מסביר את כל העניין של
המצווה להילחם נבחרת ישראל ומדוע
הייתה הבדל בין מה שאנחנו שר את מה שכאן
זה אף
הוא בעצמו נעשה מעשה.
הלך ללשכת הגיוס של
ההגנה
ישראל פלאחים ועמד עם
סרט על
נגדו
בכניסה לירושלים. יד מושב זקנים שהיום שם בתחנה המרכזית
ובדק את המכוניות שלך. זאת ירושלים, זה שירו שגם הוא הולך.
אני לא אשכח את התמונה הזאת. זה לא יודע אם זה מפורסם, שהוא עשה את זה בעצמו. עלי
למישהו אפילו יותר לעשות בשבת, לעשות בשבת בעניין. בעניין זה לא זה זה ודאי, אבל זאת
אבא.
הוויכוח היה על בני ישיבות,
והסוף הסיפור
שנשביתי על ידי הירדנים.
עד שחזרתי עברו שבעה חודשים.
כשחזרנו משום מה לקחו אותנו ישר
לזכרון יעקב לווילה של משפחת אהרונסון.
עד שראינו אותם. אנשי
השירות, הידיעות, המוסד
שלוני ברים את הדם שלו ידריך אותנו.
זה היה
ביום שלישי בשבוע,
כיס לב,
אפשין טיץ.
והנה
למחרת בבוקר, כשהגענו
אנחנו עומדים בתפילה. שם, באולם החדר האוכל,
רואים מהחלון
ערב ציוד ההולך
אופייה
הגיע באוטובוס הראשון
בירושלים. בזכרון יעקב
זה עולה שבעה שמונה בבוקר
נדהמתי,
לא יהיו מכוניות פרטיות אז ולא בטקסי, והוא בא באוטובוס.
יהודי מבוגר
נכנס,
כמובן.
התחבקנו, התנשקנו והתחיל לבכות או ילד קטן.
ואז הוא מוציא מהכיס את החוברת הזאת
נותן לי לך וכתוב עליה
לחמו נפשי
ורוחי ידידי
הרב, לא נראה שהם שם.
השמורה מיום
האהובה את החוברת הראשונה
ליום, שוב שתויה, שהיא
תביעה של ירושלים,
אומרת שנת הקטורת. היה כתוב של הקטורת, זה ראשי תיבות של שנת.
ואז
אני שומע את זה היו בתוך קופסה.
חיפשתי את זה גם בהקדמה לספר שלי, שיצא אחר כך. וזהו,
נסגר המעגל. כן,
אני אני אוהב
עוד את
הוסיף עוד שלב בחיי. עכשיו,
בתוך די השביעי
ביום מן הימים נכנס אליי
הסנדל, מייג'ור המפקד של
נישואים,
ואומר לי עם תה חם טבעת מין, הגנה
פירוש הדבר אתה עליו
של אנשי ההגנה.
התברר שגויס. אם
בדיעבד,
פעם הייתי בשלי.
אגב,
אין כזה שירות שלי כתוב ראשון השני הבאים לשמוע.
אלא אם יש עוד הרבה הרבה אנשים מתארחים במרכז שירות כזה
לשאול השני, הרבה
לפני המדינה הייתה במיאמי.
גייסו
ברבעון רטרואקטיבי
כדי שיניחו לנו
החוק הבינלאומי של אמן שנערה
ומינו אותי לדף צווי.
כן, למעשה, אפילו הפכתי לרב שלך נשבי.
כשחזרתי, הפכת. למה שני? גויסתי לתוך השירות של העמוד הצבאית הראשי.
שגישה יקר, אז הרב הראשי וזה הראשון של צה ל.
אבל זה גם אין
מים. קוריוז מעניין.
חייבים שימרו
את הפורמליות
של
האמנה שלהם. מופיע, השתנה ואדון פעם בשבועיים
זה היה שלי. הלוואי על גלעד שליט ולהעביר
הלאה, הווארד
והיו
מי שנפצעת
בעיר העתיקה.
פגיעה שייתן לך ברגל.
אתה למעשה מותרת מ פעילות
צבאית עד עד הנפילה בשם. נכון?
אז אתה היית בין הפצועים שעמדו שם במסדר.
במסדר מהעבודה. נטל שהיה אני לא אני לא אמרתי במסדר. אני הייתי בתוך ארוכה.
אתה היית לא ננקה ששאלתה בצד הייתה בצד. כלומר, לנקום בהן.
אז אתה הובלת. לא ממש. הייתי היהודי האחרון שהוציאו אותו מתוך הייז עתיקה
כמובן. תלוי כמובן כמה כדרך אגב דרך הרחובות.
אני זוכרת המרינה רבים צועקים עיריית סיינט בן יהודה
והיא הגיעה לזה שהקצינים היהודים ירו באוויר כדי לפזר אותם.
שקיבלו הוראה ברורה מאת
המלך שלהם. שעשבים צריכים להגיע החיים
לרבאט המון דרך
דרך איזה שער יצר נשאר ציונו שלו. לא יצאנו
אותנו דרך
רחוב חוז
חצר החיים. יצאנו
דרך הרובע הארמני.
הוא הוריד אותנו דרך כל השחורה של שליט סבא דראק.
פנינו שמאלה, המושא הגבינה, והוציאו לשאריות
שעבר. יותר הגיוני לצד המזרחי. המרוחק מיוחד. כן, כן, כן. ושם עמדו
המכוניות שחיכו לנו
בסרט. הם ישקיעו אותי ניסוי על, על על על אומדן אם אתה
הובלת לבית חולים, או שהובלת אנחנו ישבנו. הקבוצה של
האיש
משום מה.
איך הם בחרו אותה?
היה מצד אחד זה ערב הנגב
שהיה
יושב ראש הוועד של
המוכתר של העיר העתיקה והמשפחה שלו,
והיו שקצהו עם
בסך הכל עשרים ושלושה איש. היינו בתוך הכשרה קטינה,
שהתזמורת המלכותי של עבדאללה בתוך הבטנה,
בתוך
בתוך הבת תמר.
השפה הראשונה או כל הזמן, כל הזמן,
עד לא כל שבעה חודשים.
זה לקח שבועיים בערך. לקח מיותרת אייר עד שבועות.
כן,
זה בערך
כמה זמן.
שבועות זה במסיבה. אנשים
לחיים.
כן,
חודש כמעט
לא פחות ופחות בחוטף רב בדבר ויודע את זה שישה איש עשה. זה
יודע מחוזות שבשבועיים
וברחם של
שבועיים,
שלושה שבועות בערך שלושה
אש.
כן, לקחו אותנו לבית החולים
הצבאי של ארבעת המון.
שם היו כבר רק פרופיל י יב ירדנים.
ואני זוכר עוד קוריוז מעניין
בשנת
מיותר יהיה שזה ישא יום שישי
עד יום ראשון. היינו במגזר ממני מול שער ציון, שם לקחו אותם לשמור עלינו. אפשר
להגיד לנו בני ההמון הערבי,
בוא נמזוג במנזר הארמני. במקום
בעיה צד נשברו ברוב הארמן
ויש דלת עד היום של ברזל מול שאר לציון. שנה שם חשבון.
כבו את זה הצלב,
כי זה נראה כאשר את הצלב שאני יושב על אסלה.
שם היינו
אתה השמירה של הגיונה
הירדני
מיום שישי בצהריים
ועד יום ראשון בצהריים,
ואני זוכר ש בדל
איזה קוריוז מאוד מעניינת היחידה היא לספר אותו שישלם לדורות
הבוקר של שבת.
חוויאר תמשיל חיץ
לא ישנים כאן כל הלילה בבוקר
עם האור הראשון,
מסתכלים דרך החלונות,
מה רואים?
למרות השערות מהרובע היהודי שרפו אותה. כולם
פוצצו את בתי הכנסת שבדבר. אדוני לך
איך מה היתה התגובה?
דבר מאוד מעניין.
התחלנו לשיר
אל לנו אי אפשר בדם ויש עוד ערפדה, ויהודה תקום ונשארו
יבנה המקדש.
אני היום זוכר את הקצין הירדני שעושה ככה.
הם השתגעו.
הפצועים
מול
הפשילו את אחר. העיר
עולה ולעבוד בהם. שרים כאן.
לקח להם זמן. אנשים יתעקשו יחסו וצעקו עלינו
עוסקות וככה הם ישתיקו אותם.
אני אומר שבכוח שירה היא אנחנו. שבעה חודשים. זה היה משהו מיוחד.
אי אפשר לשבור את הרוח שלנו.
חסרים ברסלב שהיו איתנו יראג דו גברתי, זה צריך,
הצלחתי שמייבש
גם כן
דמויות יהיו חדש רעיש וישר
אל הימיות. ההורים, אנשי ההגנה.
יש תמונות.
התמונה שלי
מתוך החדר הזה של הפצועים
שנתפסה, אלבום של ג'ון קליז
ובשבילי שחוזר לעיר עתיקה.
אחי מלחמת ששת הימים מעל
הטיימס כתב עליי שהיתה יהודיה אחרון שיוציאו אותו, והיהודים האזרח הראשון שנכנס.
אז.
אז אז אני סגן ראש העיר של ירושלים. אז אני מבקש קצת הבהרה
אתם
כשהייתה קנייה,
אז אתם לא המצאתם באותו יום.
לא זה שציינת לאשר ראש היא הרעיון,
אלא יום שני לילות. ישנתם
במנזר הארמני. אנחנו כבר ממש מעבר להר הזהב העליונה שלו
בשבת. ביום ראשון ב וועדה
של רופאים,
פחית, הושיב היה אחד מהם
והיה שהצלב האדום, אנשי היום, ביחד לעשות את המיון.
מי הולך ליישב איבי לפי ההסכם אצלך
כל הפצועים ללכת לעיר החדשה להדסה.
והדלת. לארי אמר
במקלות הייתי גומר אתכם. היית יודע שיש רק
לוחמים. שליש הבוגרים
היה כבוד.
הם מוכרחים לקחת
יותר לשבי
שלך. הוא גם זקנים
וגם פצועים, וגם אני הייתי בין הפצועים.
גם זה סיפור מעניין.
האם באמת הלימודים להסמכה? לרבנות שהתחילו הכבוד שהתחילה
נובמבר הרבה
שלה.
מי שהיה אמור לתת לי את השמיכה הראשונה,
לא הראשונה, והסבירה שהוא היה להעביר זאת לכבוד
אחרי שחזרתי חזק
על עימות שלי והלכתי על לקבל שמיכה,
משפחה לא טיפה, בחנו אותי פעמיים. בחרתי שבפעם השלישית אומרת בואו נעלה לבד, הלך דרך.
אני נותן לך הסמיכה לרבנות.
נותן שיחה בנוי גבוהה. בואו נרד יחד,
יורד איתי על המדרגות בדרגות
ביי בשתי קומות,
והן שהמדרגות ותופס אותי מתחיל לבכות.
להזכיר את ארצי, אולי לבכי שלו
הרבנית שרה זכרונו לברכה. אאסוף את האישיות.
אפשר להרגיע אותו. בקרה בקרה,
בוא נראה לעשות חיים,
מכינה כיבוד לכבוד זה. חגיגה לכבוד הסמכתי לרבנות.
ואז הוא מספר לי שבשבת קוויאר
בא אליו.
הרב גורד
סיפר לו שאני בשבי, שהועדה צריכה להתאהב. את מי לקחת לשבי
ומי להחזיר לירושלים החדשה. וכמובן זה יש פיקוח נפש.
נדלקתי. למה יכול להיות בשבי
הערבי.
אז הוא טיל אפל, זאת אודותיו. לא הזכרת
שהיה ראש. היו בירושלים ששברנו לנציב
וביקש במיוחד לגבי הרב שלי לגבי שישוב. כהן
זה לא העיר.
לא התכוונתי.
אני אולי חושב אסף את האזיק
בינינו
כי
הם כל כך מעוניינים בו. סיבה שהוא כדאי להחזיק אותו בשבי. מה, להחליף שוהים
כאן? כך אני חושב,
אבל הוא הסדק באנשים שמיים.
אני לא אשמח שלא רק שחזרת מאשר אני נותן לך הסמכה לרבנות.
אז הוא התרגש מאוד היד, אבל ברגע
זה סיפור יפה,
בעוד
אני אני מבין ש
לאחר כמה כמה ימים הייתם בתזמורת בבניין התזמורת,
לאמן
איזה
הייתי אומר זה שבוע עשרה ימים. ישראל.
אני אוהב את זה.
אחרי שגמרנו,
חלק החזירו
ארצה
כחלק של חולה מכדי השוהים ומפרה השקעות הורמל ג'מאל
אפשר את משפט בעניין? החזירו
אותו. אני באיזה שלקחו אותנו להגיד
'דרך המדבר'
בדרך עיראק יהודית אני רק שווה שעה.
היינו במחנה השבויים. זוכר שהיה חושב הראשון היה
מאוד קשה.
מחנה מוכר גיטרות טייל עם
מה שהיה. נראה שיצא קליע.
התברר שזה היה פנסים סך הכל,
אבל הדמיון שלנו עבד,
ואני זוכר שיחסלו אותנו לתוך מחנה השבויים. הקימו
בית חולים בשבילנו שם אוהלים.
כבר לרובים שלנו
היה אחד בשם דוקטור ויסברג, שהרגע היה קצין רפואה ראשי
ואחד בשם דוקטור, כגון רישיון חיה כאן בחיפה
ברמה ויו אחיות,
והוא
בגוש עציון. אבל
אם
כריסטופר בעיר עתיקה מבין זמן בגוש עציון,
ואת הניתוח שהוציא מהרגל שכמעט זה הלכה לאיבוד כי התפתחה כאן גראנדה
עשו בתוך מחנה השבויים
דמוקרט שבועות אפשר לומר
איזה ההרדמה ומה לא הייתה שפכו היתר על
ומעניין שאני לא שמספרים לי שאני בכלל לא צעקתי
ולא להבין את זה היום. הייתי מסוגל
אז אבל יש לך לצרעת חזרת לתפקוד להגיד שזה טיפול רגיל על ידי מנחם מלחמה.
יש לי חמישים ואחד אחוז
שמתוכם שלושה אחוז אשב יזם
זה
הרגל השמאלית שלי. אני הולך קשה
כמובן להימצא.
היא ניצלה.
אתם מנצלים את הזמן ללימודים? בטח. אתה ניצלת את הזמן. מה זה יכול אתה ללימודי יושי?
אז היתה האוניברסיטה מ
בשבי.
אני נולדתי עני. עני. למה תגמר.
היו שיעורים בשלושה שיעורים בכל יום.
אנשי הפרופסורים, שני הטכניון שהיו
שייכים לחברת החשמל
מן הרעים לימדו מקצועות.
אני למדתי ערבית בשבי. גרמתי
מתמטיקה גבוהה ויש
לי מרטי וטלבוט. זה ממש
קבוצה מאוד
יחידה. והנדירה יהיו שם. מה ככה
ושם אנשי העץ. אלא שה לכייף. אנשי ההגנה
זה
היו שם. יהודים
מהעיר העתיקה, היישוב הישן
אפשר
קיבוצניקים של השומר הצעיר, רבדים,
חבר'ה ממסורת יצחק, שרידי גוש
כפר עציון
וכל החבורה הזאת
גזר
וכולם מחברת חשמל. מאריי
דרהאם גזר
זה מי חבורה כזאת מיוחדת.
אני באיזושהי דרך יחד עם הרב שלמה מן ההר. זה חומר הדרכה של
הדמות שכתבו עליו בספרים.
היינו נעשה הכתובת הרוחנית.
אני ניסיתי תמיד ככה למצוא את הפשרה בין
אני אומר כאן בחיפה, שבית הספר לרבנות
בעיר כזאת
קשה והוא חי ת שיש בה
חילוניים ודתיים וחרדיים
וקיבלתי. מה שבשם משם
איך באמת היו היחסים בין
אוכלי שקלים אני צריכה
ולא היה. כולם אכלו אותו, דבר
שלא היית צוחק. איך היו היחסים? נניח
של טנסי דיון ליום
היתה היתה נדבר. היתה היתה אווירה טובה. הייתה אווירה,
להיפך
כשל קירור, לראות היא היתה שותפות גורל כזאת.
אני חושב ש
הלוואי על קר כל מדינת ישראל היום ואווירה טובה כזאת.
ראש מחנה השבויים היה בחור שאני אוסף בלושטיין,
שאתה צריך להיות
ממלא מקום ראש עיריית חיפה.
הוא עמד בראש הגוף הבוחר לחבר ראשי בחיפה לפני
שנה,
והוא זה שפנה אליי והציע לי להיות מאומץ כאן
שזכר את התפקוד שלי, ושם ואני נוכל. לא חשבתי אז הייתי בירושלים,
הייתי בעיריית ירושלים, הייתי סגן ראש עיר. ראיתי
בראש מוסד שנקרא בחוד הרביעי שלו היה נקרא אריאל שני ערב חשוב איתו,
הוא טען
זו העיר בשבילך
והם לחצו עליי.
למה שהם מועמדים אחרים
אבל עם מכורים אחרים.
הייתי בבית הספר. היה שמי. יודע
מה. אם אתה יכול להגדיר מה נקודת השיא? זה
מומן
זירה. חוויה מיוחדת בתקופת השם.
אתה יכול
לספר את זה חוויות
אוכל למשל.
אני חושב שהחוויה שסיכמנו הנוראים בשם ה' הוא
האחראי על שסיפרתי על השירה בשבת בבוקר בתוך השק
אל לא זה מחנייה
במחנה השבויים. הגענו אליו
בבוקר של יום השבועות.
זה יצר. החיילים לקחו אותנו מהבית המון במכוניות העבר. שעתיים נסיעה, משהו כזה.
את ספה לתוכה, מחנה שבויים
אתה מצפה ופתאום אתה שומע מה עניינים בעניינים קוראים בתורה.
היו לי בעיות
עם ספרי התורה של עמיתיו לשם בתי כנסת,
ואז היית סת' היה כאילו אתה מתפשטים לחשל
שזכרונו של מאה שערים.
התדהמה הזאת
עם ארגון פנימי,
אמא מבכר היומיומי
שאנחנו פטורים כי פצועים ממנו.
הישיבה המשותפת
של אנשים שדאגו לסוכה בסוכות
כדי שחפרו על יד האוהדים שלהם פגומות בעומק של עשרה טפחים וכיסו אותם
עם עלים.
אמא
האלה שדאגו לכשרות,
שחטו לבד
בשביל לזכור המחנה.
וזה האופן כולם, והוא אוכל כשר
את
התחושה הזאת.
הוועד המשותף הזה.
יש
פתרון שנקרא טייד
שהוצאנו בשבי בכתב יד.
אני הערכתי אותו גם כן, וגם שיש מעבר שלי על זה שאני מדבר על האווירה הזאת של
צריכים לשמור על
אווירה משותפת.
אבל החוויה הכי חזקה הייתה
האזכרה שעשינו
לשלושים מבחינת ירושלים העתיקה ונקראת גוש עציון.
האזכרה לחברים שנהרגו. זה היה משהו
מיוחד.
למה לא בשם מיוחד מיישובים לעשות לזה לא? זה היה בלילה
בשבילכן עשה יעשו לצאת
ארגון פודקטור מסביב.
ואני דיברתי אל ינא. םתיא אפשר
עוד חברה עכשיו בכל אחד, אחד מהעיר העתיקה אחת בגוש עציון.
אני חושב שזו היתה אזכרה מיוחדת מן ההתחדשות הזאת. כן,
ואמא עם האמונה הברורה שאנחנו עוזרים
לו על אתה יודע, ברגע שאנחנו נחזור הביתה.
אנחנו ניהלנו אחד שהיה חבר חייל. השם
הוותיקה לדוד מזרחי.
כן,
הוא היה מכלל, אני חושב,
ובאמת התרשמנו ממנו באמת. מהעבירה הזו, אתם
אחת לשבועיים הייתם פוגשים מה שהצלב האדום.
כן,
סך הכל לא היה בית הבראה. אבל החיים היו שכירים. אפשר לומר
במקרה ש
מישהו דיבר לאמצע 'מפקד,
ואשר המייג'ור ניגש
והרביץ טוב מייקל
להשתיק אותו.
המכרז בשביתת רעב,
טען
יושב לו שני כלפיה,
המפקדת אשר כסף אגב, היישר כסף. אגיד לך לפני השבויים והמצב הזה,
מה זה מקים שהוא עם מה הולך כאן.
את
אחראית. חייב לתת לכם אותו יחס שנותנים לחיילים שלנו.
חייל שלנו שידבר למפקד יקבל גם כן פליק.
זו הייתה הטענה שלהם.
מה זה אומר? משהו על היחס שלהם אלינו. אבל
זה לא חזר יותר זה לא חזר.
מתי אתם מקבלים את הבשורה שאתם אוטוטו עומדים לחזור?
הייתם בעניינים לעולה, שומעים. איך שהיה הנשק היה הקשר.
אני לא יודע איך הוא התאווה, כי לא הייתי קשור בזה.
בין
המפקדה הפנימי שבך ליישובים לבין
אה,
המוסד בארץ
באו לבקר כביכול קצינים עיראקים,
אבל אחד מהם היה
שתול
שהיה מעביר לנו ידיעות
הייתה
כי זה ייראה כאילו להעביר אותנו למקום אחר. ואנחנו
העברנו
מסר שצריך לעשות הכל, להשאיר אותנו כאן ולא להזיז אותם. היא פחד מזה.
תפילה. מה
אנחנו?
אנחנו מיד סוגים.
יש
שתי דקות, ולא זה אין
קלטת.
בסדר, אפשר להגיד משפט לסיום? כן, זה
בבקשה.
אני חושב שב.
אה,
בערך זה חודש לפני שחזרנו,
יהיו הידיעות שמתנהל משא ומתן לחילופי שבויים. ואני הייתי בקבוצה הראשונה
של שבויים שהוא זרע
בימים שמעתי ש משה דיין
ואליהו ששון באו לרבת עמון לפגישה עם עבדאללה, ושם הוסכם
על
ההכרח חילופי השבויים שלי משנה בערך חודשיים,
ועל הקבוצה הראשונה שעברה אתה זה היית אתה הקבוצה שלנו.
נהניתי מאוד.
אפשר להמשיך בהזדמנות אחרת. בסדר,